here is a fun namibia fact
namibia is home to the world's largest
population of free or roaming cheetahs
mmm cheetos um
i like cheetos
[Music]
ah the position was winning too opponent
allowed rook f6 i wasn't expecting it
oh
it's all the fault of the namibian
cheetos
oh such a good position too
okay back to not top
namibia 40. a large population of cape
fur seals
ooh banana
something seals wait
seals can have fur okay one staffer
gambit
let's go i played this opponent
ah opponent is not following my new rule
i
invented a rule where you have to accept
the staffer gambit
but not everyone follows it that's okay
i don't mind the position thank you
pavanin
99 or pavo99
okay i've had this structure before and
very often i end up playing f6 and
some knight e5 move
um maybe in combination with this
yeah still want to play knight e5
always have to watch out for the
potential checks but
um i always have king here
and sometimes it makes sense to play
king h8 even
if i'm not in check
just so the king is a bit safer
24 hours question mark make sure you
drink water
i'm drinking tea water
i hope that's suitable
again i don't know if it's gonna be 24
hours i don't want to make any
uh failed promises
so it's a 24 hour long tournament like
that's a guarantee
the stream i don't know but
also if i play the full tournament i'll
only have played
am i winning that's a nice position
if i play the full tournament i'll have
played 23 hours
because i joined about an hour late
so this move might be coming
uh question is do i want to commit to f5
probably not just want to shift over
e4 bishop e7
[Music]
i'll have the opportunity later to play
f5
and generally at least in most end games
uh rook and bishop is better than rook
and knight
so
[Music]
especially when there's pawns on on all
flanks
okay now i have this
trade off a pair of rooks now go for f5
oh my rook is hanging out almost forgot
again that my
lights move backwards no maybe a fact
they have the highest sand dunes in the
world top out at 1066
feet oh that's kind of impressive i was
not expecting to learn so much about
namibia
but i feel like chad is more
more instructive than alexa could ever
be
especially with the fun facts i don't
know that one
i know you never know except when you
sometimes know
look at this move attacking the oh no my
pawn
but then bishop d6 okay so let's play e4
i'm going for bishop d6
so i'm following the positional
principle pawns on light squares
opposite color of the bishop i restrict
the knight as well while playing a game
of chess in france benjamin franklin
took his opponent's king after she
inadvertently put it in check
when she said ah we don't take kings so
franklin replied we do in america
um i was expecting something about
namibia there
but that sounds interesting
okay i gotta watch my time i mean
position is nice
some idea to push the king really should
activate
yeah let's bring the king in
if the king's on the light square and
the rook's on the dark sword i can never
get fort
which is nice
okay
okay one i mean there's g5 ideas
g5 almost traps at night actually
so if it takes i probably just play g f
oh okay let's play g5 anyway
and going for g5 again
okay now going for the the win of the a2
pawn
rookie three okay let's
take this
time management but it's looking good
i i missed the fork there
okay i want to play rook here
there we go oh no
no it's going to be a draw
[Music]
no
let's go let's go
check me let's go just got off a 17 hour
shift
need to be back in seven hours good luck
also did you want me to do time stamps
for this marathon
i have tuesday saturday off him rose and
tony m rosentoggi
i appreciate the offer probably not for
this one i'll probably do like
compilation of the best moments
i appreciate that thanks so much bicycle
um
wow so i i gave a lecture on this exact
end game let me see if i can find it
it was a st louis chess club
lecture
oh let me see if i can find it it may
have been my first lecture for st louis
chess club
just to explain it here though uh this
is a theoretically drawn enemy end game
oh thanks mcnubbits dirty checkmate
so actually when i uh when we traded the
uh the rooks i realized this was gonna
happen
i knew this was wrong i knew there was
some chance of still winning
um so
is 2017 this is probably 2017
so i share oh this is a really cool
position though
[Music]
um the other reason to underpromote is
to avoid stalemate
because the queen is so powerful in some
cases if you promote to a queen it's
stalemate
oh yeah promoting to queen doesn't work
there
this is a cool position if people want
to solve it
um uh it was october october 8
2018. so i guess it was one of my later
lectures for the club
dating idea it should be an easy draw um
and this is a draw with uh without too
much trouble
now i will say there is one trick in
this position oh maybe it's just
supposed for white to win maybe you've
seen it before
so there is a trick in this position if
um
if white plays a move let's say it's
black smooth let's say black plays here
and okay let's say black gives away the
pawn oh let me fix the a5 then there's
king f7 and this is the one thing black
has to be concerned about is king f7
with discover checkmate um so black
would have to play a move like king
the guy in the video looks exactly like
you
as long as oh it doesn't work for me
it should be an easy draw but not not
present just to demonstrate even further
let's say black actually gives away the
pawn
uh in this case let's say king here here
here
uh now let's say bishop c3 oh okay so i
did check
the move do you play king h8 or king
yeah of course king f8 um i've seen this
actually happen once in the game where
the player was just moving back and
forth between h8 and g8
and didn't realize this pattern and then
just got mated so you have to be very
careful
uh in this situation as black when uh
when you're given the choice don't walk
into bait
okay so that's basically what happened
in uh my previous game
uh
[Music]
yeah this game maybe i'll have to maybe
just make a compilation
or put together like that clip and the
game
just for youtube